hello guys my name is Jono and welcome
to the fourth episode of reviewing my
load and a game that I made it ages ago
called Genesis so last time and I never
spent a while since the last episode and
I'm not gonna get into wasting time
talking about why and stuff you know why
it's me anyway so today we're gonna
basically move on to what I promised
we'd move on to last time and that is
the delighting and how that works and
all that stuff so by lighting of course
I'm referring to the fact that we're
gonna basically overview the entire
lighting engine engine if you can call
it that it's very simple and we'll talk
about how it works and how it doesn't
work as well because there is a bug with
it that we need to fix and I mean I like
I have not done any overview of this
lighting in like I haven't looked at the
code at all right what you see in these
videos is the extent of my exposure to
all of this code right since I wrote it
like since back then right so I mean I
haven't like done my homework on this at
all
so because of that the nature of these
videos is gonna be quite live as you
know and also it kind of gives you I
guess an insight on under how I kind of
work out how certain code works right so
I mean right now in this point in time I
have no idea how it works at all okay
I've no idea I mean I remember certain
pieces here and there but I mean I
couldn't tell you what class had sent
even like I don't know what it I don't
know how it works at all okay so that
III think that Korea is kind of like a
unique thing I mean I just don't have
the time to obviously go through all
this and look at my own code that I've
written ages ago and works out
unfortunately but I think on the other
hand like whilst that would lead to
probably more concise and better you
know quality videos this also gives you
the other kind of perspective which i
think is quite unique and cool so anyway
and I'm also going to and also I have no
idea why the bug that is happening is
happening okay I still don't know when
it's been four years and I still don't
know why that bug is happening okay so
today whilst we're not gonna prioritize
fixing it or anything because of course
we're gonna just overview all the code
for the game first and then we'll move
on to like creating a to-do list and
fixing everything I think I've already
credits them to do actually if we got a
window I think should I show you and
then tasks then maybe yeah so to do
was to catch this thing for the font
stuff so potentially means excuse me I'm
a little sick as a little kind of sick
ish as well so just bear with me if I
start like coughing whatever Oh anyway
so the idea is what kind of you know
we'll do this we'll go through the code
first then we'll work out how to fix it
and so on that but I will be keeping my
eye out on actually on why that bug is
happening so as I go through the
lighting code I'll be just in my in the
back of my mind I'll be like could that
be causing it what's going on so anyway
let's excuse me let's take a look at
what I mean by lighting one thing we are
going to do or try to do it's going to
the level class here and actually see if
it might be possible to increase the
day/night cycle so this game has a
day/night cycle in which I guess the
brightness dictates whether it's day or
night yeah exactly so the brightness is
greater than twenty it's day if the
brightness is less than negative two
hundred it is night okay obviously the
speed at which the brightness kind of
goes is I guess right in the spot class
maybe that doesn't make any sense
because okay if it's day if it's night
okay so this like this should never keep
this this should never be hit basically
but we have basically the speed at the
brightness here I think the time method
which is really what does everything yes
is dictated by this kind of this is how
often it wrongs so if we were to like
you know decrease this or something to
about ten it should be a lot faster
today nice like five times faster in
fact which might not even be fast enough
so let's just basically get rid of it if
we do something like that then you can
see how fast that day/night cycle is
that might be a little too fast I might
make it fall okay and let's get into a
good okay so what we have here is
basically the day/night cycle and the
lighting of this game so things you can
notice first of all brightness decreases
of everything except for what we have
these torches in which case they emit
light now from what I can remember it's
very simple as to how it works I'm going
to actually take a screenshot of this
real quick and maybe boot up paint not
even paint on that apparently just paint
so we can kind of decipher this and
because you can see it's already like
it's already going the other way so
we'll keep that running in the
background but
just take a look at this okay so what we
have here is essentially you can see
that the areas that have the torch right
the brightness of the adjacent tiles to
that torch is kind of dependent on the
distance that it is from that actual
torch right
so moral more or less some kind of
diagonal distance here not distance in
terms of tiles like Manhattan distance
or anything it actually just looks like
you know kind of as the crow flies kind
of distance a direct distance right I've
forgotten the name for it a you a
Euclidean distance I think is what it's
called
it's the acquitting distance rather than
a Manhattan distance of course and then
that kind of dictates the brightness of
the tile so you get this kind of
interesting thing well obviously
diagonally we have to travel for the
distance which is why this tile is
roughly the same kind of brightness as
this tile and then this tile and then
this tile and we kind of get a nice
effect where we kind of get you know we
don't get like smooth lighting in a
sense that it's not completely smooth
it's actually kind of restricted to
tiles as in tiles have a brightness
value associated with them and that
brightness value is the brightness value
of that tile there cannot be such thing
as like a tile having multiple
brightness values or a tile having a
gradient of brightness right a tile is a
constant brightness has a constant
brightness value and that did that
dictates how bright the tile is and
that's that right which is why you can
see that each tile basically has one
color associated with it
right it's in no way kind of a gradient
or anything like that it's basically
flat and that's that of course is just a
stylistic kind of aesthetical choice
that I've made because I think it looks
a lot cooler especially with again it's
kind of low resolution you can see that
like obviously these characters and man
paint is really terrible but anyway you
can see all of these kind of characters
here obviously low resolution this water
isn't particularly cutting edge or
destroys the music was going through all
of this I hope you guys can hear me all
right
yeah you'll be fine anyway um I mean
it's color it's kind of like a low kind
of poly I would call it game I don't
know like a low fire coming yeah I'm
obviously pixel excellently so there's
kind of I decided to make the lighting
like this because I think it would set
it quite well anyway that's how that
works
okay so in terms of brightnesses it's
very simple lighting should work
in a very simple way this is if I'm not
talking about entities right now just
about the actual level and against the
like at the actual terrain and
everything on these tiles so you can see
that like essentially just to summarize
that the distance the Euclidean distance
from the light source is what or rather
the brightness of any given tile is
determined by its Euclidean distance
away from airline cells a light sauce
okay very simple yeah I mean that's how
lighting works right I mean in real life
the further away you offered a light
from a light the dimmer that surface is
going to be lit right now when we have
surfaces which collide like this I
actually don't remember how I handle
that I think it actually isn't additive
I think it's actually so let's find two
torches that are really close together
if that even exists these two might be
yeah you can see okay so this is
interesting because it looks like these
are actually darker than if they were by
them yeah Nick you can see that the way
the lighting works here is it looks like
it might be multiplying the values
together or something like that because
this this results in being a darker tile
even though you would expect it to be
brighter because there are two lights
okay so instead of being additive it
looks like it is actually being you know
some kind of multiplier or a scalar so
that's probably wrong as well and I
don't know if we want to fix that
because that one line doesn't that not
necessarily you know manifests itself as
a whoops sorry microphone as a bhag per
se but I kind of don't like it so maybe
we'll have a go fixing then a lot of it
to my to-do list okay so anyway so if I
seem like I'm talking a little bit fast
it's not because like I'm hyped up on
speed or coffee or anything like that
it's because I know that these videos
gonna get out of control really quickly
as far as time goes so I'm trying to be
as concise but also have a lot of
so anyway you might want to watch this
video to half space who really want to
don't do that okay so that's the way
that that cookie crumbles does that
phrase again that I should stop saying
yeah here we go
exhibit a lighting bug you can see that
the player is still kind of lit so now
when we want to insulate this entity is
still lit even though he's far away from
the light okay that's wrong and like the
way that entity lighting is supposed to
work and you can see these aren't lit at
all even though they kind of stepped
into the light they're the way that
entity lighting is supposed to work is
that there is no kind of flat there is
no kind of flat
I guess flat approach to entity lighting
right it's just like the the feds like
the firt like that your distance your
your Euclidean distance from I really
hope you're clearing distance is the
right term because I've been saying it
all over the place let me just Google
I'm pretty I'm like 90% sure it is but I
just my mind is like where is my mind
right now yes so straight-line distance
or equilibrium distance just just
double-checking that's all
like literally you're kind of
straight-line Euclidean distance away
from an entity to a light source is the
brightness of that entity okay but for
some reason you can see it lit yes as
he's working right now yeah like you can
see I kind of fade in smoothly and then
I fade out smoothly as well when I leave
the light cells it's just sometimes it
doesn't work for some reason and that's
the bug because you can see like yeah
like it's not it's not even smooth now
and you can see that it looks like I've
went to the light it's increased my
brightness then I've moved out of the
light and the partners has remained okay
so I think there's something very fishy
going on with that and you can see like
some of these entities
I just various brightnesses it's almost
like they've frozen a bit at a
particular incorrect brightness level
instead of actually yes see now it's
kind of working so it's one of those
bugs that unfortunately doesn't happen
all the time I'm sure if I actually read
the code a bit like yeah well this is
stupid this is what's happening so it
might be really simple to solve it might
not be again you guys are welcome to
like pause this video and look at the
code yourself and figure out why it's
gonna happen I don't know yet if I
actually find the reason in this video
so maybe we'll find it and we'll be like
okay this is will write it nor it being
like you need to fix this and this is
the reason why it's happening
or we might not or we might be like this
is a bit tougher than we thought so
we'll see okay cool anyway that's how
the lighting actually works now let's
look at the code so from memory the
level render function of course the
render method inside the level class is
where all of the tiles get rendered
therefore the lighting has to occur
there somewhere because that's where the
actual pixels from the texture get put
onto the screen from the tiles texture
get get put onto the screen where does
that actually happen so let's go through
this code a little roughly and I'll kind
of comment on it so we have we're
working out basically our bounds here
like our X x0 x1 and y0 y1 for corner
pins for what area of the level we want
to actually render and then it looks
like we just rented the tile that's it
so that's interesting
because then we have all these other
stuff that looks like the same thing
it's not really so get TAS ok so just as
a little test let's just put in if true
return and I'll just put on one on the
same line just to see what actually
disrupters okay so it looks like we get
ok so it looks like we don't get the
animated tiles so the water or unless
that's a different level what level is
it I think this is the island one and we
don't get any kind of lighting and we
don't get the trees so this is this
first thing looks like it just kind of
renders static tiles and not lighting so
that's weird because I guess I would
imply that light tiles get rented on top
of this oh and you can see torches
aren't rented either so if we do the
next block nothing should happen right
because all we're doing is we're adding
tiles to lists here there's two this
three lists it looks like light tiles
post render and tree tops so I guess
this is where we actually render the
live tiles so if I go back here you can
see that we get the actual and most like
I'm stuck somewhere that's weird oh here
we go
wait maybe that was a different level
not hang on yeah that was a different
level why is this so slow hope is when
I'm clearing it
okay let's clear that should be a lot
faster there we go um okay so anyway
this is yeah okay so it looks like a
tomato tiles are actually in this list
yeah that was my bad
I thought we were in this level anyway
um so this is got three that'll be our
reference these three rocks so we have
yeah bunch of tiles here or a bunch of
Lights here you can see the light tiles
are indeed rendering correctly and
everything's fine our post render
consists of which by the way we are
adding a ton of let me just I guess
we'll move this up here so we we have
post render which is basically things
that I guess get rendered on top of the
ground so stuff like trees and possibly
torches yes torches as well and then of
course we have and I guess I'll just
leave this carrot here because it's fine
anyway and then we have the entities
being rendered such as the player and
stuff and then we have the tray tiles
being rendered now of course the
treetops are rented after the entities
so that we get this kind of so that we
get that we can go like this now so that
we get this kind of obstruction effect
where the player can move behind the
tree right that's why it is how that
works we just simply render all the tree
tops which are these things alright we
simply render them after we were under
we rendered the entities and the player
and stuff brilliant so that's how that
works
pretty simple so of course the thing
that we're interested in is is actual
live tiles not only the actual rendering
of the lighthouse but also how we
calculate whether we need light tiles
and of course this is not the efficient
code by any means I mean we aren't
creating a lot of data here but looks
like if the tiles an instance of a torch
tile that is when we need to add looks
like live tiles so
this is interesting and possibly wrong
honor hang on
all right no sorry I misread that whoa
okay that's interesting
how's that okay so it looks like okay
right so this is the same as our loop
except we actually go it looks like we
go three tiles three tiles extra so we
expand our point a logger like visible
area like by three tiles in each way
which is why we had the minus 3 and plus
3 and that I guess is just so that
things don't oh no no no no I know why
that's because of the lighting because
of course yeah I remember now
that's because of the lighting because
of course even if the torch is not
visible we still you can see
coincidentally the three three tiles
happens to be the max distance of a
torch yeah otherwise if we didn't if we
had if we said it's like two for example
let's just experiment for that and you
can see that that last chunk disappears
yeah that's why we wanted to be three so
that we can kind of go all the way to
the torch and then get the value for
that so that's why that's set to eat
like three on each side
I mean I know whether or not we need the
actual treetops and stuff to be in in
this for loops probably not but it is
what it is okay so this is the first
thing we do we create a light tile so
what is a light tile so a light tile is
it looks like it is simply a coordinate
which also has a tile object in it and
every time we create one of these we add
it to a static list that is actually
located in the light tile class which
contains old live tiles okay so pretty
pretty straightforward pretty normal
like there's nothing really like wrong
with that approach or anything so far
and that's what we do so by the time we
finish this we should have an
appropriate number of light tiles so
let's say for example after this well I
probably stopped it when we actually get
into a decent socket that's a lot of why
okay so that there's warm like there so
let's just stop that so how many light
halls do we have one okay so it's
interesting so that's interesting right
so it looks like whenever we have a
torch as you can see well I mean you
could read the code probably guessed but
every time we excuse me every time we
have a torch
we actually add a new light tile in like
X&Y being of course the torch is current
location yeah so every torch on the map
not every toss on the map every torch on
the map that's visible in the current
viewport right so that is visible to the
player or is within three units outside
of the visible area okay all those
torches we take their position and we
create a light tile at that position
okay and that's it so that that that's
how that works that's it so now what we
have is basically inside this light
tiles ArrayList we just have a bunch of
light tiles one for each torch okay
that we can see or whose light we are
supposed to see because it's within
three units outside of the view that's
outside of the viewport outside of the
viewport okay so um and that's what
happens and then what we do is we go
ahead and render all of the actual light
tiles which I guess and we're about a
look at that obviously but I guess what
that does is just goes through each of
those tiles and then just on a nerd
renders another tile on top of our
existing tiles with a varying brightness
or something we'll see what happens
parameters that we pass into it seem to
be this is weird as well we pass in the
X and the y how is that because render
is a no that's weird
okay so this is like for example passing
this in is completely unnecessary since
of course it's located in the live tile
class but we do it anyway screen we pass
in and we also pass in the level object
which is interesting so x and y again
are just equal to this so we could have
just used these I don't know why I
decided to pass them in I guess I wanted
to be consistent or I was rushing
because every other render function like
I mean the render functions inside tiles
so go to like torch tile or something
you can see that those render functions
do take in an X and our Y even though
this one didn't have to so I guess I did
it there as well but usually since tiles
are just kind of you know flower tall
like tiles since we don't have a
separate instance of the tile class for
each tile we just have like one instance
we of course need to provide it and we
need to tell it where we want it to
render in this case because there isn't
like a child doesn't know usually that
that's wrong okay because you can see it
like eyes in we don't need this this is
probably isn't used at all because you
can say that we credit our statically
yeah
which means there's one instance of each
tile rather than having one instance for
each tile like as in there's one
instance for each tile type instead of
having one instance for each tile on the
map which would be very slow he don't
want to do that but for torches I think
I did do that
maybe I didn't I don't know because this
is very confusing again we just call
public into X Y in random places even
though it's never used so that's a bit I
guess that's just typical web and there
but anyway this is the meat of the code
of course so we get the current level
brightness this is important because
this is the ambient light essentially
okay I call it TB now I don't know what
TB stands for something brightness maybe
target brightness I don't know anyway
we basically clamp the target the I
won't call it that because I don't know
what it is we clamp the brightness to be
between negative 240 and zero so it's
always gonna be a negative number so one
thing we should keep in mind okay and
then we go and this is all in terms of
tile kind of spacing right as in like
we're not dealing with pixels here at
all these x and y that gets provided to
us I believe are yes are in terms of
tiles tile coordinates it is at our
coordinates not like pixel coordinates
okay so then we go through basically an
area here that is exactly a six by six
tiles right no no we go through an area
that's seven by seven tiles because we
count zero of course then we go all the
way up to three including three so we go
from negative 3 to positive 3 inclusive
so it's a total of 7 tiles and of course
that is what generate this grid you can
see that we have seven tiles here 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 and 7 tiles across here so
that's what that followed this nested
for loop right here like the first two
don't worry about the level yeah that
nested for loop is literally just going
through this two-dimensional area here
okay that's it
starting from the top left corner yes
starting from the top left corner and
then of course going looks like a row by
row until we get to this okay
now then once we're inside a tile so
what this is used for is basically let's
just say so the first iteration we would
be looking at this tile over here so we
look at that tile over there which we
interact about four times for some
reason with slightly what is it this
code I guess that's about we do here so
we multiply X by 16 so we convert X into
pixels from tiles into pixels since each
tile is 16 by 16 pixels okay so we
generate a value that is between
negative 1 and 1
I believe that will give us negative 1
to 1 either negative 1 or positive 1 no
1 2 ok this will give up it is either 0
or negative 1 if I kept no we multiplied
by 2
hang on I'm confused now I've confused
myself
today's the one dirtiest no that should
be but that should either give us
negative one-on-one so we're basically
deciding whether or not something will
be positive or not then we multiply by
seven which is about half the size of a
tile if you start from zero okay and
then we divided by sixteen again that is
odd card looks like we kind of that is
weird
why am i doing that Wow one earth is
that four so it looks like what we're
trying to do is like get I just don't
understand as time seven thing it looks
like we're like wet so well on this tile
and then we're going a little bit to the
left on the first iteration there but
like to half the half of this tile or
something and then of course we're
dividing it by 16 which would round it
down because it's an integer division
and then we try and get that tile why
did I write it that way though that's
very weird so what this does is against
the four adjacent tiles in a diamond so
if we get if we thought our first
iteration we said we start off with this
tile what this code should do I expect
what it will do I don't know why it's
written like this job knows but it's
gonna get this tile this tile this
basically if we're here right it's gonna
get that tile that tile a tile in that
house so the four adjacent tiles that
are not diagonally adjacent this will
not get diagonally adjacent tiles or
will it I don't think it will so that
should be negative one negative one on
and I hang on I might be completely
wrong yeah maybe it'll get the four
corners
I gave her back in time I would slap
myself running this monstrosity this is
ridiculous I think it actually might
give us negative 1 negative 1 negative 1
negative 1 negative 1 the first time 1
negative 1 the second time negative 1 1
the third time and 1 1 the second time
oh the fourth time all the third time
let's see that's my prediction so it
should be maybe something along the
lines of that I actually think it might
be that but again I'm just let's just
say
oh well yeah I mean it takes X in
compared to X so I guess we'll do minus
X minus y okay
okay so I was wrong about the right
bound
with a left bound seems okay so we get 0
negative 1 ok so I was right
but then that we don't have that more
this is this is I didn't think this is
correct I mean I didn't know what this
is doing let's actually rate yeah
there's the tile I wants to talk for
underlying so weird so we had welcome to
live videos no no this is this just many
sense we even do 0 0 what wait what X X
X T plus xx
thank you let's do this
maybe just will clarify something maybe
not okay so this looks like potentially
one line here maybe we should find an
area that only has one line like this
that's something go online right there's
nothing else around whoa
oh but hanging out but it's doing it
Fraser the tiles yeah okay that makes
more sense do that do we need like why
why can't we just do like because I
guess we're trying to get the current
tile but I don't understand let me try
something
this is I just I actually don't get mice
like why this is the way it is no clear
let's try some I just want to see why
why this wasn't an approach that was
possible because this seems like
extremely incorrect especially because
you can see that we reassigned tile four
times like why why would this not have
been acceptable
is that any different
nah that's identical
is it or is that a little bit different
I know sound what will be different it
should be identical or is that what is
it because I'm saying like this thing
that I can't actually see over here oh
maybe that's cuz I'm a bit too high
that's what it was yeah that's
definitely there okay so it's identical
man I don't know I don't know what this
crazy carrot is and I don't know why my
master don't let's quickly go through
the maths of this just so that I can
validate it
so I'm want to when I is zero this is
gonna result in zero we multiply two by
0 so we get 0 and we get negative 1
that's how we get the negative 1 bound
okay and then for y on that case I
divided by 2 zero divided by total it
gives us the same result so we do
definitely get that at the first time
the second time when I is 1 we should
get 1 1 times 2 is 2 minus 1 is positive
1
which is why I wrote that and then I
divided by 2 so 1/2 is going to round
down to 0 times 2 minus 1 is gonna be
negative 1 so we get that when I is 2 we
go back to this being the same as what
it was before which was negative 1 this
on the other hand is 2 divided by 2
which is 1 times 2 which is 2 minus 1
which is 1 which is why we get that and
then when I is 3 I'd I'm 3 mod 2 is 1
times 2 is 2 minus 1 is 1 so we get that
and then so my maths is right and 3
divided by 2
Roseanna 1 times 2 which is 2 minus 1
which is positive 1 so that that maths
is correct okay anyway I don't know man
I'm actually just going to delete this
because it's upsetting me and it's
incorrect furthermore this does not need
to be a natural thing okay I promised I
wouldn't change any code but it's upset
me enough that I have changed the code
anyway and I assume that that is indeed
doing the right thing yeah
yes it's in tall tile precision rather
than pixel precision all right so we're
at what 30 minutes incredible okay
doesn't matter bookie going that just
took me way too long but again it makes
it like I'm glad that it wasn't just me
non standing I think that code was
actually just alien code that someone
like I don't know actually
if anyone can find the point in the
livestream I think it's all on this
channel at which I actually wrote that
code and just like send me a link to
that I would be very very grateful
because I I want to know what I was
saying when I was writing their code
anyway
okay the nice thing we do is we
basically grab that offset of course and
find the pixel that we need to find this
our thing which I'm assuming stands for
radius will basically calculate so we
square we times we multiply where we are
by PI and square it so we're basically
doing PI R squared and then where it
looks like where this is fun okay yeah
and then we okay sure
okay so let's get rid of the ABS because
anything squared is gonna give us a
positive value anyway that's step one
okay or was that an extra ABS I don't
know doesn't matter this is definitely
gonna be positive
and let me I just want to verify didn't
break any of the bracket orders or
anything okay so that's all we're doing
so but that's yeah okay
yeah sure fine so this will what is
should technically do is give us a
distance away from the light source or
rather I should say it should give us a
are but not really
yeah okay I can kind of see what is it
coming from
very weird code essentially what this is
going to do is I mean you can picture it
as kind of it's a circular radius around
let me just get like red
so essentially what it's supposed to do
is basically figure out which kind of
ring we're in okay based on where we are
in the for loop so obviously if we're a
negative 3 negative 3 we fall into this
outer ring otherwise if we're negative
tornado 2 or in the inner ring or the
middle ring and then negative 1 negative
1 here and then of course 0 is just
gonna be in there all right so it's kind
of figuring out where we are there which
is an interesting value however the
value we get here is going to be I mean
it's gonna be a decreasing value but
it's also going to be random in the
sense that you can see that we have like
we start off with a large value like 128
then we get to the inner to the middle
ring which is 30 at 78 then we get to
the the third ring in which is the
almost the target ring and then we get
to the last ring okay so like the values
as you can see a very random isn't like
there'll always be that actually so they
don't really random but I get it they're
kind of useless to us they're just like
some arbitrary value it might've been
smarter to actually map this to a
certain range because all we really need
to know is like hey this means like
we're four units away this means we're
three is away this means we're 2news the
waves being a 1 in a way or something
like that so it's a little bit
interesting as to how that works but
yeah that's just how I've written it of
course this will be done for each tile
you have to remember so I guess it is a
little bit more than figuring out which
ring where necessarily in because if
we're it's also yes I should say it's
also figuring out yeah because what this
will do is it'll actually this will and
it'll end up yielding that to be further
than that I guess because if you look at
what value this would be this would be
negative 3 0 right and this on the other
hand would be negative 3 1 or negative 3
negative 1 right which if you
- you know do this mass and we can do
that right now I mean we'll look at all
the pie because it's we really don't
need the pie I don't know why I've used
the pie maybe I was like ah you know
circles radius radii let's stick a pie
in there anyway
don't really need a pie here look
another pie but if we take a look at
this mat this is of course will give us
3 squared which is 9 + 0 because it's 0
squared and this will give us three
spokes 9 + 1 square which is 1 so this
will basically give us value of 10 this
tile this value will have at 5 9 so you
can see that it's a small value because
it's basically closer that's kind of
like how I figure it out because of
course if you look at this whole grid
that we've kind of made up what we end
up having is you know I mean zero zero
being the middle and then anything out
here is gonna be like you know I mean
this tile here is negative 3 negative 3
this is the max value which of course
would be 9 plus 9 which is 18 which is
why it's so dim so in a way this R value
for each tile in our grid will figure
out how far away it is from the origin
by using only square why do we I don't
even know maybe I was halfway through
like Pythagoras theorem or something and
then I just gave it and then I just
decided this would this would be enough
for something but literally all we had
to do and I guess the squaring is kind
of okay yeah I don't know honestly it's
not too bad I'd probably get rid the pie
though anyway in fact I'm just thinking
honestly what we could have done is just
probably added the numbers together in
an absolute fashion so just math like
ABS both not both I'll use and they're
just add them together and that would
that would give you enough data I think
but anyway I haven't done that so then
we work out this weird intensity thing
so we have this radius which again is
the distance of the cart R from the
origin which is the 0 0 tau which is the
middle we multiplied by the level
brightness okay and then we multiply by
zero point zero zero zero one two very
specific okay I probably spent like an
hour tuning that value or like a few
minutes at least and it's I can assure
you that's completely random so
basically what this should do is give us
an intensity factor if you look at what
this is
I mean let's see what this is and of
course you can see it's being multiplied
by the level brightness as well which is
why it's like didn't kick in until now
you can say it's basically a value
between it's a always a negative value
keep in mind because this level
brightness is always negative so it's
always gonna be a negative value look
like between roughly negative 4 or so
and Z and 0 again they're never it's
never gonna be positive ok so then we
take that we take that negative value
which is our intensity and then we
possibly to screen rent a lot or we
leave through if the radius is less than
100 so if what that will do in practice
is basically eliminate these these
corner tiles so you can see that's why
it almost looks like this is kind of a
circle because these tiles are too far
away to actually be here even though
they're in our grid so we're like this
for loop is covering them they're too
far away based on this maths based on
this radius and so because of that let
her get any lighting applied to them
okay and that's how you kind of
otherwise you would get like a grid
which we don't want okay and then screen
render light takes an intensity which
keep in mind is a negative value it
takes in a color as well and then with
that intensity we tint it seems okay and
then we call collar up ten okay I see so
I am really confused as to why that's
negative but will you know that I guess
it is weird isn't it and then we have
this subtle value I guess we okay so
first of all we've determined that RGB
is actually the other way around so
that's like ah GB I think or something
like that we covered that in a previous
episode and also we've also kind of
determined that the way that we do this
is we basically grab the original color
of the tile that we're about to render
and then we scale which is a weird isn't
it because I mean we are like that
should be the red channel I don't know
it's all it's all weird I'm all but we
give it a negative value that's probably
why I think that might be a bug as well
let's just take a look at this so
intensity probably be zero yeah
let's wait a little bit until it kind of
gets dark I can stop destiny is negative
1 R is 62 okay so weird so we get the
red channel from this 87 we got the
green Channel from this one Oct 5 we got
the blue channel so it looks like we're
rendering across tile this is going for
every pixel by the way and then we so
we've reduced the red channel the green
Channel and the blue channel and then
with client we clamp it
so it's acceptable now we return the
value and so that's what our color is
now so we've basically reduced our color
and brightness it would seem in the
render light function and we reduced up
our brightness
okay Oh throw another iteration real
quick so our color used to be 87 165 and
95 and now it's 1389 and 18 and that's
cold rendering light oh no I know why
that's because that's an outer thing
let's go back into light tile yeah so
what we want to do is we want to just
hit resume and then what's xx and YY
negative 1/2 so let's just give it a
minute so negative 1 negative 1 a guest
should be brighter keep in mind though
that it actually might always be
reducing brightness and that might make
sense so this brightness reduction
should be a lot better as in like it
should be a lot like it shouldn't reduce
as much light so if we have the same
values 87 we can see them up here 97 165
95 and now there so you can see that
that was a very kind of small reduction
in cooking I think because you have to
remember that the original tile is
actually very very dark because the
level like the level of the level
brightness has been applied to all the
other tiles and so what this is doing is
it still has to dim it a little bit it's
just that it obviously dims it a lot
less based on where it is so that's it I
mean that that's all there is to this
lighting we'll cover more blooding and
like interesting lighting next time
because we're way over time this is like
I mean we're like 42 minutes which is
what like a normal episode of like a TV
show like a drama series so um that's my
cue to to end this but basically I mean
that's how it works
it's it's actually really simple
obviously I was telling you guys this
from the beginning now I know how it
works which is good so just to summarize
this last part for each of the kind of a
grid of not of what is it seven by
well 49 times really no I can't be right
really hang on where's my painting yeah
Wow okay so in a grid of 49 tiles just a
lot yeah okay so in our grid here of 49
tiles we go through each tile we
basically give it an intensity which is
how much reduction we want from the
original sprite which is obviously
bright as if it's like fully lit by
daylight so we calculate an intensity
being not an intensity to add light but
rather how much light to subtract or how
much brightness to subtract from the
original source sprite okay and of
course calculating that is based on its
position in our grid and then finally if
the radius if if the if the tile is lit
at all then we apply this friend Ally
thing which renders another tile on top
of the original dark tile which is like
this color cuz it's not with less
reduction in brightness than the
original ground tile would have had okay
and that's how we get our lighting okay
so it's a little bit interesting I would
have done it very differently if I did
today I guess probably the thing that I
would have done would have been maybe
not render the tile twice maybe actually
just while you render the tile quickly
calculate whether or not it's in the
light so in the original rendering
passes when I would have applied the
light instead of me this way which is a
little bit weird but sure this works I
guess and it's almost like a post effect
it's almost like a post process kind of
effect that this thing is because of
course it's being applied to the
original image but it's not like it's
being applied it's like the tile is
actually being opaque we rear-ended on
top so it's a bit weird but of course
that has nothing to do with mob lighting
which we'll look at next time as to why
I like certain mobs are not actually lit
correctly but in terms of this you can
see that's the way it works now the
other question is why on earth do
multiple tiles that are in light
actually all like we work we were we
were talking about like whether or not
it was a multiplication kind of factor
or whether whether
in addition like as in how were to
lights actually communicating and it
turns out the way the two lights add up
is they don't it just takes one of the
lights it like because of course what
this will do is just overwrite like
it'll just render on like an additional
tile on top so whatever light happens to
get rendered last that's what you will
see if two lights across so that's the
answer to that anyway guys thanks for
watching this video hope you enjoyed if
you did please hit like button now I
always forget to mention this why it
don't but I never have it off
automatically but if you guys want to
follow me on twitter like all so social
media wires the best place to follow me
just apps there with all and stuff and
know what I'm putting out videos and
stuff is going to be Twitter become
full-sized sure know if you are
interested in my life which most of you
I know passionately are then you're
gonna want to also follow me on
Instagram because I mean I've been like
taking just photos pretty much daily and
just posting a lot of stuff so Instagram
icon for the channel is very very active
so if you just can't get if one video
per week which is what I'm doing right
now just not enough for you guys then
this is like the best place right now to
interact with me and and to see what I'm
up to
because because cuz I've been I've been
instagramming a lot lately
alright but anyway I'll see you guys
next week I don't know if I'll put out a
game programming episode or this episode
I might start alternating so one week
Genesis one week game programming I
don't see what you guys think we'll see
what the response to this video will be
like I mean if it's a lot because
Gambhir gramming I think is dying down a
little bit which is why if you guys
actually enjoy this video you need to
hit the like button because that's
literally how I decide what kind of
video to make I look at the likes and I
say okay this one has seventy likes this
one has 200 I'm going to probably make
the one that has 200 right it makes
sense so that's how I roll anyway see
you guys next time good bye fool
you